you know that rain will pass but traffic
headaches in the valley May persist for
over a year it's because of long-awaited
drop mechanic construction dropping
tomorrow it will be happening at
Tropicana Avenue in the I-15 now some
closures just for a couple days others
four months Ryan Matthey is there now
joining us live with how this could
impact daily commutes really Ryan across
the valley
across the valley that's correct Brian
and actually officials are calling this
a valley-wide traffic event a lot of it
stems from that Tropicana Bridge right
over my shoulder here you can see how
popular it is with all the cars there
now this closure uh it has a lot to do
with that bridge it's not tall enough
for the modern standards we have large
trucks keep hitting it so they're
tearing it down and rebuilding but a
year and a half of impacts are expected
let's talk about what's immediate
starting tomorrow night around 11
o'clock southbound I-15 drivers will not
be able to exit onto Tropicana in either
direction for two weeks this is in
preparation for larger closures ahead
that includes a hard close on Tropicana
between Las Vegas Boulevard and over the
freeway for eight days and then a hard
close on the I-15 both directions
between Russell and Flamingo for three
days if you remember after the Christmas
holiday there was a 12 mile backup from
Gene through the California state line
should drivers expect something similar
that's what I asked officials
it certainly could happen I mean the
main message that we're saying is if
unless you are visiting one of the
fabulous resorts on the Las Vegas Strip
where you or you work down there you're
better off just avoiding I-15 during the
weekend of that closure it's going to be
heavy traffic both North and southbound
and yes there's a detour but we know
that detour is going to get very crowded
very fast
now these hard closures will let up by
the 30th that's two weeks from today
access to Tropicana from the I-15 then
getting across the highway on Tropicana
will be disrupted for 9 to 18 months
respectively the department could not
give me an exact number of minutes or
hours they expect to be added onto these
extra commutes so what are drivers
supposed to do how are drivers supposed
to navigate all of this I have that
coming up for you tonight at 4 30.
reporting live from a very windy
Tropicana and I-15 Ryan Matthey a news
now Ryan thanks for breaking all that
down now making that bridge higher is
just one aspect of the project it will
also widen the sidewalks for pedestrians
go into T-Mobile Arena or even to a
legion Stadium add extra Lanes on the
road and increase traffic flow in that
area